everyone we are still here at e3 2017
not going anywhere playing all the games
talking about them one of the big
surprises from Ubisoft press conference
was a new game called skull and bones
yeah Alex you played it tell us a little
bit about it so I think the first thing
to know is it's literally Black Flag
pirates spun off into its own game but
it's multiplayer this time one of the
coolest things about Assassin's Creed 4
Black Flag was the naval mechanic
getting to explore around in a pirate
ship that you upgrade in and stuff now
they turn this into school and bones and
it's basically what you think it is it's
black flag except multiplayer a little a
little bit more involvement right so
it's its PvP right if you're not like
just exploration in that kind of stuff
so you all be taking on other players
and doing kind of like the ship to ship
battle so yeah so the the mode I played
was a five-on-five mode where you square
off against another team you're you have
to take down this convoy that has a
bunch of gold in it and if you take them
take those ships down then you can
collect the loot these are the convoy is
like NPCs you can collect the loot and
then the other team will come after you
and try to get the loot from you okay
and then the more loot you get and the
more convoy chips you take down the more
likely pirate hunters are to show up and
that sort of signals the end to get end
of the game and uh at that point you
have to make a mad break for the escape
point
thanks cool and you get like different
types of ships and yeah and they all
capable of doing different things right
yeah so and the build I played there
were three different types of ships
there was the marksman the enforcer in
the bruiser the marksman is like a
sniper you can you have a long-range
cannon you have a really long range
mortar so you're really gonna want to
stay back and pick off ships from afar
the bruiser was a larger ship on that
you can go in and it's sort of like the
tank right and the enforce is sort of an
all-around ship pretty agile pretty able
to move with a really really nice
broadside cannon
and is there what kind of depth that
they introduce to the actual sailing
stuff because I'm I found Assassin's
Creed sailing to be quite involved but I
guess they'd want to introduce more
skill to it yeah they want it to make it
a competitive multiplayer thing right
have they done that definitely and the
thing that I was actually a little bit
unsure about was they have made it more
realistic so and black flag your ship
felt super agile it felt like you could
you know zoom around into really
whatever you want and this the wind
really matters so if you're going with
the wind you're going to be going around
ten knots but if you're going against
the wind you're only going to be going
about two knots okay so it's a really
huge to keep them to be aware of where
the winds going where you are in
relation to the islands because I got
blown into the the rocks a couple times
and this so the ships go a lot heavier
as a result of it they feel a lot more
unwieldy like ships would yeah and I
don't know if I really like that at the
moment what I see more I guess well as
they introduce new types of ships we've
got like three now but perhaps they
could have more that kind of like let's
say it's slow and kind of like agile to
get around and kind of cause trouble
right and what kind of modes they show
you was it just the five buddy five yeah
it's just the five you five and they
mentioned that you could play solo in
the in the announcement trailer and
Ubisoft press conference I don't know if
that means they'll have a solo campaign
yet why not more about that yeah I think
it's one of the games that they didn't
spend too much time showing off but it's
definitely something that a lot of
people will be interested in yeah
especially after the success of Black
Flag it was so kind of like taking the
idea and really running with it in a way
that kind of I appreciate I like that
kind of mechanic will be interested to
see where it goes from here and see how
it develops I'm definitely looking
forward to playing it so that's a Skull
and Bones the soft multiplayer pirate
game and if you want to check out more
games from press-conference we've got
trailers for them and we've got
impressions for them going up on the
YouTube site and on the website itself
and we'll see you next time for the next
impressions video ye
[Music]